for the first time the Justice
Department is leading a statewide
investigation into allegations of abuse
by Roman Catholic priests US attorneys
have subpoenaed at least seven of
Pennsylvania's eight Catholic Diocese
sources tell CBS News the Diocese of
Buffalo New York is also now a target
Nicky Bateses here with the search for
hidden information from Catholic leaders
Nicky good morning to you good morning
this federal inquiry is unprecedented
investigations of sexual abuse by clergy
members have historically been handled
by state and local authorities but after
scathing reports alleging abuse across
several states the Department of Justice
decided to step in
federal prosecutors issued the subpoenas
to Pennsylvania diocese demanding
confidential files and testimony from
high-ranking church leaders
investigators are seeking a broad range
of information from possession of child
pornography to priests transporting
children across state lines this is a
moment in history like we've never seen
before when it comes to child sex abuse
Marci Hamilton is a constitutional law
expert at the University of Pennsylvania
and the founder of a child abuse
advocacy group my assumption is that
there are many instances of priests in
the state of Pennsylvania taking
children to New York
or to New Jersey to the New Jersey Shore
I think those are probably moments that
this investigation is looking at pretty
closely the federal investigation
arrives on the heels of a nearly 900
page state grand jury report in August
which found more than 300 Catholic
priests in Pennsylvania sexually abused
1000 children over more than 70 years
we're about to find out canon law
outweighs federal law Sean Daugherty
says his former teacher now defrocked
priest George Coe hajeck molested him
when he was in grade school he and
another accuser recently confronted ko
Hajek about their past I'm gonna tell
you this I'm angry with what you did
Daugherty says he's been overwhelmed
with messages of support the Attorney
General watched it told me it was very
powerful and it would help people
and then a lot Daugherty says he's
spoken with federal investigators but
would not say what they talked about the
DOJ and the US Attorneys offices across
Pennsylvania declined to comment
all seven diocese we heard back from in
Pennsylvania confirmed the federal
inquiry and agreed to cooperate with
investigators
John Nikki all over this story under t
is a hero for speaking up in him saying
we're about to find out if canon law
outweighs federal law that's the truth
it's very good to single him out both of
them for coming forward and speed people
stopped me on the street yesterday to
talk about this story how moved they
were